now it is the it's the 16th anniversary
you know of September 11th and so we
haven't talked about it very much and
I'll I think I would like to talk about
that in my final thought so I'll put on
my smart glasses it's the 16th
anniversary of the September 11th terror
attacks my sixth grade math teacher
broke the news to us in suburban New
York my mother saw the Towers fall with
her own eyes and from Harlem she made it
onto one of the last trains out of the
city some of my classmates parents
didn't make it out of the city not that
day and not ever after the second plane
struck father George Rutley ran from
midtown to the Twin Towers to offer
wartime absolution to the firemen
rushing into the buildings the first
confirmed death on that day was a
catholic priest named michael judge next
to the towers in st. Peter's Church the
first Catholic parish in New York Father
rattler met fireman who carried father
judges body and recalled quote they put
his body in front of the altar it was
very moving there's a picture of the
crucifixion over the altar I remember
blood coming down the altar steps I
shall always remember that scene the
image of oak's st. Paul's letter to the
Ephesians we wrestle not against flesh
and blood but against principalities
against powers against the rulers of the
darkness of this world against spiritual
wickedness in high places sixteen years
ago President George Bush put it in his
own words and I'll leave you with that
the pictures of airplanes flying into
buildings fires burning huge huge
structures collapsing have filled us
with disbelief terrible sadness and a
quiet unyielding anger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]